dude me and my girl trapped we got baby
needs babies coming November why don't
we figure it out right now I said Brian
jr. she wouldn't happen she wouldn't
have it
Brian's a [ __ ] name name name let's
come out with it it's [ __ ] - [ __ ] I hate
my name I wouldn't even let you name
them that so let's let's go let's go
with this hold on let me just throw out
some names all right Griff yeah I don't
want him just to work in a junkyard what
else you got
Gus No hold on I just like names like
you know I'm like a little substance
it's like almost like Tanner all right I
feel like you like you like like strike
or her yeah I do I like those kind of
names I don't know why but I'm striker
okay how about Cain Velasquez how's that
little ass kiss
Cain's a good name Cain's a good name
James get Luke actually I like um you
like Luke Rockhold yeah hold on
I also love Luke it's a good name I love
Luke Rockhold in Japan actually some of
the best people I know Luke Thomas yeah
Rockhold yeah Lou but Cal come on Kelly
Kelly for a boy yeah I like Kelly is a
name um if it was a girl as your name
her bow ah it's a great bow
I got a name in a sign for my son but I
what is it tell me when I pick I'll tell
you off here because I don't want fans
trying me yeah and I don't be skewed
yeah I know but it's cute as [ __ ] is
there anything I always think cuz here's
the thing that's the way dudes doing
locker rooms
whatever you pick you gotta realize
they're gonna give him a nickname so if
his name is you know like my name is
Brenna or Brendan
they called me Bren growing up or did
she call me by my last name job you're
gonna call T tiger T or T T my TIG take
your big dick pic right Bry Brian Sun
light huh picking the names interesting
though you know it is but we got I'm
gonna show you the list I want the fans
chime in because I don't be swayed on a
pic but uh is there anything is there
anything to say
my brother Liston of course he
such a sports nut he said well that
reminds me of this and this reminds me
of that city and I'm like I'm like what
are you a [ __ ] were you [ __ ] do
you have anything on the schwab you like
it it's not all about sports all the
goddamn time I'm like you name your kid
Jordan magic and Larry they just all
sports legend is there anything is there
anything about like is our Spanish name
is there an Italian name that's what
made my girl you not I mean
Lorenzo let's name him like Pablo yeah
no no but Lorenzo like just kidding why
like why it's racist why it's good
there's some cool names yeah we'll see
dude I'm gonna show you the list I don't
be swayed by mâche the list dude how
about just change topics here how about
why don't you name an amount of sound
like huh it's calm honey how do you
pronounce it that'll go over well for
him Wow I think it chicks being like
whoa that's hmm and then insert his name
there you go name Joe okay
you're just first name Brogan hey ma'am
Bufo for UFO Jesus Chris they will fall
about later
what about loves our [ __ ] Lazar laws
our shot these are shot Oh as you guys
know Chris D'Elia was on this rack I
didn't how big this is I didn't see it
dude dude
yeah it's so big I love it
do you haven't to play this it's so
[ __ ] cool Chris is in this so Eminem
place Chris D'Elia
what Oh Eminem plays Chris D'Elia then
tweeted out I am NOT Chris D'Elia
that's awesome I mean he's blown up to
another level
it's insane dude I watched all this yeah
you can fast-forward to this this so
they get the kid off Sandlot right and
then keep going yep keep going keep
going stop yep right there this is Chris
really show the dead body he's so good
he's good there's a reason he's getting
Jack to fast-forward to where Eminem
plays them which is how amazing it's my
the biggest rep he's so good and then
then Eminem copies him
look that's Eminem and you tend to be
Chris D'Elia this is crazy
I didn't see that oh my god it's been
out for I don't know since Friday at
that 14 million views
that's incredible how cool is that wow
he looks good dude he's getting jacked
let's get jacked for a role yeah oh
that's yeah big time big time or I'll -
oh yeah he's blown the [ __ ] he's gonna
be the next I'm in there I said it
hmm yeah it was crazy might be good for
a Batman or something like that be
hilarious an Australian father of three
died last December because he's known
amongst his group of friends for being
the guy who will never turn down a dare
at a Christmas party his friends dared
him to eat a live gecko which he did and
he basically grin and bear dit through
the pain for about ten days until
finally he just had enough he went to
the hospital where they have to induce
him into a coma
they found that he actually had
salmonella that got so bad that his body
was just trying to get rid of the poison
that was essentially in his stomach he
started leaking all these fluids and he
eventually actually passed away this is
in the news now because his family is
actually trying to sue the hospital for
malpractice
they're saying that they should have
given him a catheter in order to kind of
release some of the fluids from his body
and that's what led to his death oh yeah
well you don't expect like ice when
people are somebody's leaking from their
testicles which is red the sizes great
size great Phil's and his balls were
leaking typically that's where you go
you swallow Gekko question has swollen
balls look at me give me the eye and be
honest
swallow a gecko you pulling a couple off
a wall and did you swallow it it's a yes
or no it's a yes or no question it's a
yes or no question but I yes or no party
line I like the part yes or no question
oh there they are and they're leaking
everywhere god somebody hasn't jerked
off for years
Oh swollen balls why we're elastic pants
you [ __ ]
that's a bomber what a shitty way to die
it is horrible and you don't want to die
in a dumb way right yeah that's on you
swallow a gecko lots of ways to die that
just suck not sucking but when the
vending machine falls on somebody at the
break room it's like oh yeah over a
Pepsi right yeah how do you say that
being kicked to death by a cassowary
what would be the coolest way to die
that would be a way yeah no it's a way
that you'd be like ours well anything
like a in a Dwayne Johnson movie where
you're like saving somebody but you
actually didn't make it I think saving
somebody from a big cat a big cats
coming you go get in the car and you run
and the cat takes you but you but you
die fighting
though there are these two girls I know
you die fighting
doing [ __ ] against a big cat um unless
you're a man can't like myself in which
case you get bi who I used to [ __ ] in my
boarding school he was there was a guy
was [ __ ] on top of the toilet that
your honor he'd [ __ ] on top on top of it
you know what the flusher that part with
the water he would take a clean nice
round poopoo right there and he was
doing that everywhere and they never
caught him and he wrote I believe he
wrote the mad [ __ ] strikes again
dinner yeah you left a calling card hi
always leave a call I mean he used to
always leave a calling card Patrick
Beeman's dad can I tell you about about
the first time ever first the only time
I ever [ __ ] my pants I was in Ohio and I
met this girl before I met my wife and I
brought her back to my room and we hung
out had a great time and all that stuff
and I had to go do morning radio so I go
do morning radio and I came back and I
turned like 31 and someone had told me I
forget what comic he was he's like once
you turn 30 within that first year or
two you're gonna shoot your pants
there's no way I'm never gonna show my
past I love dudes who have the truth you
start [ __ ] he's like you're gonna
[ __ ] your pants is like okay so I write
III went and did morning radio and I
came back and I pressed the button in
the elevator and it's going up and I had
just this the intense hot flash I'd
never had something like that before
just it came over me like a wave and
instantly like sweat beads permeated on
my forehead and I just go oh what was
that and boom just instant yardsale on
your answer right in your poo poo pants
I just [ __ ] my pants it just came out
bad like you like there wasn't even like
a thought of like did I just [ __ ] it was
like I definitely just [ __ ] my pants no
I knew it and then the doors open a mic
mouth [ __ ]
so I come out and then I go to my hotel
room and I'm like oh [ __ ] what the girl
still in my room and I swept the key
she's still in the room like [ __ ] so I
shut the door I took my pants off and I
ran over by the Pepsi machine I threw my
pants away yeah come back to took a
shower nobody knows a [ __ ] my pants
right yeah I crawl into the bed yeah the
girl wakes up she goes oh my god I go
what she goes Oh God I go what she goes
I'm so sorry
Oh what are you sorry about she goes
sometimes want to drink too much I
pissed the bed and I pissed your bed I'm
really sorry and I was like it's cool
she goes what I go yeah it's cool yeah
she goes you're being really nice about
this us like yeah yeah well human she's
like well thanks for being so cool and
in my head I'm like you want to see how
cool I am follow me to the Pepsi machine
let's see how cool yeah
my back ripple and I pull myself up like
a champ like a chimp 2:30 time span
while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a get it's a gift it's a gift